hello dear colleagues please we are
ready to to start again our
meeting
the main point of uh of
this morning agenda of course is uh the
exchange of views with our dear
commissioner Mrs Kadri Simpson the
commissioner for energy and a very
special guest of itra committee Mr
fatigue roll the executive director of
the International Energy Agency on the
consequences on EU energy policy one
year after Russia's Invasion and War of
aggression against Ukraine I would like
to welcome the two distinguished guests
and of course with this it is important
to look what was achieved and how we
took the necessary measures and very
good measures in order to
counter attack the actions direct
actions of Russia and of course the
undirect consequences of the aggression
against Ukraine but also uh
to look here in the future because
unfortunately the word is not over yet
some will fear of some excalibation and
it's important in this context we need
to respond with urgency to the several
challenges still in terms of security of
Supply uh maybe the high energy prices
infrastructure bottlenecks bottlenecks
and of course to look to the
geopolitical context which was changed a
lot and what we expect in the coming
months and maybe years in the field of
energy policy that's why I'm really
grateful to commissioner Simpson and
executive director by berol for having
accepted our invitation to frame this
discussion giving their insight and the
extraordinary expertise and of course
have this exchange of views with us
we
have first the introductory remarks of
the two guests then the first round of
political group coordinators or
Representatives then the replies the
feedback from them and then the second
round we have already a number of
speakers so please colleagues respect
the time immediately after this will
have also a press conference I will have
a press conference together with a
commissioner and executive director by
saying that I go directly to
commissioner caddy Simpson for her
introductory remarks please and thank
you once again for being here
honorable members good morning
and I'm grateful for Christian and it's
committee for organizing this debate um
to Mark the one year anniversary of the
repower EU strategy it is very timely
the Russian war against Ukraine has
caused a tremendous shift in Europe's NH
system in one year
the transformation triggered by the war
and by repower you has been
unprecedented in a moment I will talk
about how far we have come and
delivering three power UI gender and
about what lies ahead but first I want
to look at what um this dramatic air has
meant for Ukraine and its Energy System
12 months ago Ukraine was the main gas
transit route towards the European Union
40 PCM a year based on the trilateral
agreement concluded in 2019 it had a
large power sector synchronizes Russian
and the parallel system even if plans
for synchronization with the European
greed barrier in the making Ukraine
hosted four nuclear power plants
including the largest in Europe and was
committed to work on improving safety
with the help of the Union it was
reforming and modernizing its Energy
Regulatory framework so fast forward one
year since October Ukraine's power
sector has been under constant Russian
missile and tone attacks the latest took
place this night ukrainians have endured
constant sacrifices Europe's largest
nuclear power station in saparosia is
occupied by military forces in violation
of all International conventions with
great risks for nuclear incidents
that the clinicians say engineers and
nucleics but it's are risking their
lives every day and this very moment to
prepare and replace damaged
infrastructure disruption on this scale
could have brought any Energy System
into sneeze but Ukraine has not given up
it has resisted Invasion and Europe has
stood by Ukraine every step of the way
we were able to synchronize or
synchronize the Ukrainian and moldovan
electricity Network in the base of three
weeks instead of two years as previously
planned and we introduced a strong set
of sanctions against Russia including
the Weyland coal
we delivered 1 600 generators and
thousand four hundred Transformers to
Ukraine and I set up a dedicated fund
with their energy Community which today
totals 180 million euros in places
as we go forward we will continue to
support Ukraine currently we are working
to promote decentralized production of
electricity with off-grid solar panels
and last Friday I welcome to offer by NL
to provide Ukraine
panels produced in Europe and this is
just the beginning and I invite all
member states and companies to join this
initiative and scale up
and I'm also working with sensory to
make sure that the electricity trade
volumes can be progressively increased
for both imports and exports
we have integrated Ukraine in the gas
joint purchasing platform
with a view to help secure two billion
cubic meters of additional gas and we
are working on Market reforms in the
context of the accession process and I
continue engaging with the iaea to
insist that the occupation of support
nuclear power plant is a crime
and a danger toll and every effort
should be made to create secure Souls
honorable members of the European
Parliament I wanted to start my Rick
marks with Ukraine because this is not a
Side Story it's at the heart of our
empowered actions the invasion of
Ukraine was preceded by a manipulation
by Russia of our gas markets to
destabilize the union and create
uncertainty gas supplies have been used
to leverage blackmail and divide member
states to weaken the resolve to pose
nine just and illegal war and such
actions made it crystal clear that the
union should put an end to a massive
dependency we had a Russia built over
decades and this is exactly what we have
set out to do with the power UI agenda
many doubted that
was it even possible but one year on the
shift
in the European Energy System is
spectacular let's take gas
diversification as an example since
September 2022
Russian gas is about eight percent of
all pipeline gas imported to EU pipeline
gas imports from Russia amounted 61
billion cubic meters last year the First
Cash supplier to Europe is no longer
Russia it is Norway
some doubted that Europe would ever be
able to receive the LNG
that was needed to replace Russian gas
due to the limitations in the physical
capacity of LNG terminals but facts tell
a different story in less than one year
three new terminals were open and five
more will be open by the end of this
year for a total capacity of 50 PCM and
in 2022 we received in total 135 billion
cubic meters of LNG from the global
market
for from the United States for instance
instance we received 56.4 this is 34
billion cubic meters more than in
previous years
the increase of cash supplies from other
sources and Russia was almost 10 percent
higher than they estimated in the March
republication and overall the Europe
phased out Russian gas by two-thirds
we packed up this diversification effort
these new tools we have introduced a
common storage policy in three months
thanks to the work of this committee and
it's about the professor buzak
and this has worked well we filled
storage up to 95 by November last year
and it's still around 57 percent this is
more than twice the level of our
underground car storage last year and we
have introduced a framework for recorded
casting production all member states
committed to reduce their consumption by
at least 15 percent and they did so
demand dropped by more than 19
percent between August and January and
this helped us to save 42 billion cubic
meters of gas
we have set up an NIH platform to
support diversification and Joint
purchasing and we have introduced a
mechanism to correct price peaks in the
DTF gas market not justified by the
fundamentals of global markets and we
will propose to extend MCM to all other
hubs and we did all that without
derailing the green tea
last year carbon emissions dropped in
Europe by two and a half percent
an important part of real power EU was
to boost Renewables deployment to
replace gas in power generation and
heating and this has matched
expectations and possibly exceeded them
last year we generated more electricity
from wind and solar than from gas
so 2022 was a record here for solar
energy in the EU with 41 gigabytes of
new capacity installed and wind
capacitors Rose uh by 15 gigahertz so
last year 39 percent of our electricity
came from Renewables and this
wide-ranging change happened not just
because top down instructions from
governments it was a Grassroots movement
with Europeans leading the change they
have installed millions of solar PVS on
the roofs they are putting heat pumps in
their homes and they have adjusted their
Lifestyles
um this was sadly driven by high energy
prices but not only everyone has played
their part
that is where we stand today but the
value of our discussion is not in
looking back it lies in looking forward
to the next steps
so let me conclude by making three
remarks on the future
first on the outlook for the next
heating season we are in a good position
when this winter without any shortage
and to start the next refilling season
with confidence and half full storage
will explain in a moment so we should be
under No Illusion that things are
getting easy this year will be
challenging and the year after that does
well many uncertainties remain and we
need to keep a healthy and prudent
Supply
demand balance
I am going to propose to member states
to prolong the voluntary demand
reduction by 15 until next year
this has worked well and it's best
guarantee to achieve another great level
of storage by November we will continue
and extend our efforts at
diversification around the world and to
ensure reliable supplies to Europe
second we received last year around 20
billion cubic meters of Russian LNG
I think that we can and should get rid
of Russian energy completely as soon as
possible still keeping in mind our
security of supply and I encourage all
member states and all companies to stop
buying Russian LNG and not to sign any
new gas contracts with Russia once the
existing contracts have expired
committing not to renew existing
contracts as Russia
is the best way to give a long-term
Assurance to our reliable partners that
meaningful demand will stay
third
in my view Europe will win this energy
War when we finally deliver on our
renewable energy objectives for me the
end goal of Ripa Rio is not to replace
one unreliable source of gas it's
another trusted source of natural gas it
is to leverage Europe's energy
independence by Massive increasing
Renewables we need to accelerate our
installation rate
and to that end we need to take five
steps this year first the dialogue on
the red three must be finalized as soon
as possible I welcome the progress that
we have had so far but we need an
agreement on ambitious targets and a
robust enabling framework by the end of
March second we need to use all the
potential in particular on biomethane
and heat pumps but I will launch a
practical initiative to promote
biomethane
by the end of this year and
um
you can also expect from from our site
that we will
present a strategy on heat pumps
and third we need to accelerate the
construction of large-scale offshore
projects we have two Summits this year
one in all standard another in Lithuania
and we will need to make progress fourth
there is a need to look at Creed
developments to remove a serious
bottleneck and I'm advocating to include
Creed Manufacturing in our net sale
industrial act that will be presented
next week and finally I will prioritize
incentivizing Renewables in the reform
of the electricity Market design we need
a reform that will help bring down
prices and protect consumers but also
that strengthen in incentives for new
investments in Renewables
honorable members one year ago many
would have said that ending our
dependency from Russia is Mission
Impossible and look at where we are now
this is thanks to our unity and also the
work of this committee
let me thank in particular you
chairperson
um you have been a great interlocutor
even when we had these difficult choices
with article 122 proposals and we have
come a long way but we still have a
tough job ahead of us
so um
I offer all my
cooperation to you but um
only together we will be able to deliver
the necessary missing pieces in our
legislation this year thank you
thank you thank you so much dear
commissioner thank you for all your
involvement congratulations for
everything it was achieved thank you for
coming so often Twitter committee to
discuss to take the input from our
colleagues the good ideas that
contributed also to the decisions that
were taken and of course thank you to
hold the whole team from dgnr and
everyone that you coordinated for the
good dialogue during this year of Crisis
and of course we are looking forward to
work very closely together in the future
we have a very
important privilege to have here with us
today the executive director of the
International Energy agency Dr fatik
birol uh extremely knowledgeable with a
very strong voice during uh this year of
crisis of War but not only of course
even before uh with the most important
challenges that the International Energy
sector but also European energy sector
faced and with a lot of very interesting
solutions that I'm looking on the
website of International
Energy agency Please Mr we already have
the floor now
thank you very much Mr chairman Mr busek
Madam commissioner dear members of the
parliament is a great privilege for the
International Energy agency to share our
views about the European
an agitation of today and also tomorrow
dear colleagues 24th of February was a
major milestone in the history of energy
not only for Europe but for the entire
world
because
Russia the country that invaded Ukraine
is not any country when it comes to
energy
as of 24th of February
Russia was the number one
energy exporter of the world
number one in oil
top oil exporter number of other Natural
Gas
major player in the coal markets
in electricity markets and Beyond
so therefore it triggered the first
Global energy crashes with implications
for everybody
in the world
but of course Europe was at the
epicenter of this crisis
so today in the next few minutes the
recordings I would like to talk under
three headlines one
is a congratulations
second is a warning
and third is an indicating an
opportunity for Europe
first
now many people thought as of 24th of
February and there was a lot of visual
thinking from Kremlin and as for that to
Europe as a result of resisting
against Russia together with Ukraine and
the International Community would mean
in court Europe would freeze
and Europe would have major economic
damage
but European countries
and the commission moved in solidarity
in a pragmatic way
and took very urgent and right decisions
and International Energy agency
only one week after the invasion
on first of March came up with a 10
point plan which we have suggested to
European governments
and today I would like to show you why I
think it is time after one year to
congratulate European union and the
institutions
that I we are a number driven
organization
we make our hands dirty with data every
day
so just with the numbers I want to show
you why it is time today after one year
to congratulate Europe and European
institutions
number one
we have seen that the in one year of
time
Russian oil and gas revenues
a major input for the Russian budget
declined by a major 40 percent
this is in my view a major help to
ukrainians and ukrainians defense
and our analysis show that dick decline
will only deepen in the next months to
come
the second indicator
the share of Russian gas in Europe in a
very short period of time one year is
very short for the energy sector in a
very short period of time decline
substantially
another good indicator
Renewables
a huge increase in renewable energies
mainly driven by solar but also wind and
others huge increase about 40 percent
this is driven by also
by the fact that many countries see
renewable energies not only a solution
to our climate problems but also a
solution to our energy security problems
energy security was a key driver of the
big renewable growth
heat pumps again a big cropped
Poland is the leader but in Finland in
rest of Europe we have seen huge growth
in heat pumps to reduce the gas
consumption
we work very closely with the
manufacturers of heat pumps around the
world
in Europe they were always complaining
in the past that they don't have enough
work to do now they are still
complaining because they are not able to
meet the demand coming from their
customers
electric cars also a big cloth
so all clean energy
options increase while the gas decreased
and many people thought and said Europe
has double standards
Europe ties the world that the we have
to reduce the emissions and Europe is
using a lot of coal therefore European
emissions will go up where is the
European instructions European views
and these views are driven to be wrong
as well
because our numbers show that the
European emissions decline is a
significant 2.5 percent
so dear colleagues last year
in the middle of the first Global energy
crisis European get the epicenter we
have seen that all the efforts from
Europe and its Partners we were able to
see Russian oil and gas revenues decline
the share of fresher energy in Europe
decline
cleared energy options increase
and Emissions decrease and we have not
seen a major blackout or heating
problems
we did have some bruises economic and
social bruises that's for sure but this
is far less worse than it was taught
before so therefore my first point is
congratulations to Europe and European
institutions include the commission and
Madam commissioner here
the second point education is a warning
as I mentioned to you
yes we are as it seems we are off the
hook if I may say so this winter
but another winter is coming the next
winter
and there are three factors
that are with us now and that may not be
with us next winter so therefore I see
in some government leaders when I talk
with them a bit of a overconfidence
about the current
achievements now and therefore is my
warning my warning is next winter may be
more difficult
then this winter for three reasons
number one
this winter we were lucky to import a
lot of LNG from the markets to replace
the Russian Pipeline gas
and one of the reasons that we were able
to import a lot of LNG is
China
which is the top LNG importer of the
world Chinese economy was bet
Chinese domestic gas consumption
declined for the first time in the year
2022 since 40 years
therefore Chinese LNG Imports decline
significantly therefore there were a lot
of LNG in the markets and we could go
and buy this LNG
but now
all the indications show that the
Chinese economy is rebounding
therefore China's LNG import needs will
be increasing therefore China is coming
to LNG markets is a major strong buyer
with strong financial muscles this is
the first reason of the warning
second reason
every year certain amount of LNG
projects finish and they come to the
market
available for the buyers
this year
2023 the amount of new LNG
capacity coming to Global markets is one
of the lowest in the history
only slightly higher than 20 BCM which
is very very low
therefore the pool of LNG
is rather small for Europe to to buy it
this is the second reason
why the warning third
we have to be honest with ourselves we
have to be realistic here that one of
the factors had us
this year
to
go through without major problems is
that we had a relatively in fact more
than relatively a mild winter
nobody can guarantee that next winter
will be a smile test this winter and if
it is in line with the usual
temperatures then this may be a problem
therefore
it is my warning here we shouldn't be
too relaxed too overconfident we should
be happy with our achievement our
solidarity our Unity our pragmatic
policies but get ready for the next
winter which intense energy agency is
again working with the member countries
providing guidance and suggestions to
them this is my second point
and now my third and last point
it is about the European industry
in September
last year
I wrote by saying that the Europe needs
to have a new industrial master plan
because there are two major pressure
points
number one
Europe
industry is based on a model
which is
basically getting the rather abundant
and cheap Russian energy
this is finished
there is no going back
European energy in the future will be
more expensive than in the past
this will put a lot of pressure on the
competitiveness of the European
Industries as energy is a big part of
the production cost of Steel aluminum
cars whatever you chemicals whatever you
produce
if your energy in
much more
accidental competitors you start from
the disadvantaged position
we read
the current European energy process came
down compared to 24th of February crisis
this is true and this is good news
but dear colleagues
even today's
Energy prices in Europe
are three times higher than the
historical averages of Europe
Three Times Higher
European natural gas prices today
which people say came down which state
which is right is seven times more
expressive than in the United States
so yes natural gas is seven times
cheaper than a European natural gas
prices
which came down
yes but they are still three times more
expensive than the Chinese electric
suppressors
so therefore we have a fact here
and this will not change broadly
in the future Europe energy process will
be higher than previous European energy
process
and higher significantly higher than it
is economic competitors
therefore European industry policy needs
to change this is the reason number one
why there is a neat new European
industry master plan
number two
We Are The World Is entering
a new Industrial Age
the age of clean energy technology
Manufacturing
it is the batteries
it is the electric cars solar panels
windmills
smrs and all of them
and who is going to produce this
currently there is one country
is making a major major inroads it is
China
when I look there you look at this chart
you see that China is currently
dominating the game
for example batteries which is the main
component of cleared energy in many
reasons 75 percent of the batteries in
the world is today
manufactured in China
and United States came up with the
inflation reduction act to be a part of
the new Industrial Age Creed energy
technology manufacturing and our numbers
show that even Euro Ira the inflation
reduction Act is fully successful
God's seamless the 75 percent of the
share of batteries the in the China's
share of batteries in the world will go
down only to 55 percent
and what about Europe
and I think Europe needs to be also the
part of clean energy
technology manufacturing and it is the
second reason I believe Europe needs to
analyze in the entire supply chain
of clean energy
where Europe can have a Competitive Edge
and what kind of financial economic
and also energy policies and need to be
put in place
otherwise Europe industry will be first
producing
not competitive products
and producing obsolete products
and it is the reason why we need to see
a new European industry master plan in
line with the new cost of energy
realities and in line with the next
chapter of Industrial Age
if not and I am finishing here I believe
European economy
will get a big hit
and as the industrial sector
is a major backbone of the European
employment
we will see significant employment and
social uh pressures and a weak European
economy and being less competitive in
the industrial sector would mean the
Europe's status in the international
Affairs will be diminished
so these are the three points I wanted
to bring to attention the first ever
congratulations of the last year
performance and heads up for the next
winter and every chapter longer term the
industrial competitiveness and
opportunity Mr chairman thank you very
much for the time
thank you thank you very much thank you
for uh reminding us some important
realities for uh uh telling very clearly
what many of us are thinking that uh the
bad days are not over yet I hope but
could we should prepare maybe for some
difficult situation uh during next
winter and you you gave the main reasons
and also okay of course uh uh looking to
the industrial competitiveness of our
industry uh Nishu very dear to the heart
of many colleagues in the committee I go
now to the first round uh please uh dear
colleagues and please also dear guests
to respect now the times because we have
a press conference at 12 15 and the
journalist generally expect us to be on
time there but we have enough time for
our dialogue and I go with the first
round the round of coordinators or
representative of the political groups
the first intervention Mr Cristiano Epp
coordinator
I mean we had been
thoroughly reading what the EA had been
publishing and my first question is from
both sides
um do you Mr Bureau have the impression
that the commission takes and the member
states take the right measures
and the same question goes to the
commissioner is the commission but also
what is the impression by the commission
are the member states taking the right
measure to consider that Gap
second question
um you have commissioner had heard what
Mr Bureau saying on the competitiveness
we are discussing now on
a proposal from the commission on
clean hydrogen
there is nothing mentioned about
comparative costs
so have you any idea what are the
comparative costs of producing clean
hydrogen related to your proposal given
that in terms of the IRA an investor has
a precise idea of what is are this
energy cost because the Americans
addressing the cup X
and they have a precise idea about the
cost of hydrogen so where do you see
your proposal because it's described by
the industry in seikos as
overcomplicated over descriptive and we
did to much higher comparable costs than
clean and clean hydrogen produced in DS
and my last question is a little bit too
um the market interventions and the
dreams here I mean
um we should be grateful that the
commission like a crap was going
sideward when asked to intervene in the
gas market prices because it was an
um let's say the way the council wanted
to solve their own problems internally
by handing that over to the commission
but let's have a look I mean what in
effect happened is that the ECI that
operates the tdf mark in the Netherlands
has out of virtual trading point in
London now in case the gas price Gap is
triggered so I would like to ask you I
mean how do you see that I mean the
effect of all that balihu was simply
that we are shifting out the trading
hubs out of Europe
so what do you expect in terms of
potential intervention into the electric
electricity Price Market
I think the first League proposals we
see that as fairly positive but I mean
in relation to what happened on the
intervention attitude of the gas market
what do you expect from the electricity
market and the results of an
intervention from the Commission in this
market thank you thank you thank you so
much
vice president of the committee on
behalf of snd
director of the agency
today's meeting has given us a lot to
think about
for our future and present work so very
interesting indeed
Madam commissioner
we have been able to face this emergency
with a terrible shock that came out of
the war in Ukraine and all its
consequences we've managed to overcome
that terrible moment
by combining emergency
measures such as storage
and at the same time pursuing a medium
and long-term strategy to change our
Energy Mix
and thinking about new actions for
Renewables what are we going to do so
it's not to rest in our Laurels which we
can't afford to do
in the short term
and immediate measures
well commissioner I think the issue of
prices which you touched on quite
rightly
is now Central
how
can we make sure that our stocks our
needs as stocks give rise to an
excessive demand and increases that we
can't afford we actually have to reduce
prices so how do we do this do we buy in
bulk do we buy together
there are different disparities in costs
in a lot of countries it's higher in my
country than in others this has an
impact on uh not only Italian industry
but to the single European market
so what can we do Beyond member states
uh uh Goodwill they're not uh
getting together
to
create what I think is an inevitable
future which is an energy Union
how can we
get other energy into the mix I think
biomethane is important
but we need everything we even need
hydroelectrics but I'm not going to go
into that now so the initiative that you
talked about for biomethane is a market
that's having trouble getting off the
ground it's very fragmented it's a small
units we need somebody to bring it
together we need a policy and rules but
we also need
uh industrial policies
regarding industry we have to help
Breton and the commission because part
of that industrial policy should come
out of our energy policy I think they're
a bit uh distant at the moment we've got
industry and energy on two different
sides of the world we have to have
uh energy leadership in all these
actions
thank you very much chairman
Madam commissioner
executive director on behalf of the
renew group
I would like to thank you for being here
today
to mark this sad first anniversary of
the war and to jointly analyze our
energy strategy
we've published several reports one that
explained that in 2022 World energy
demand increased by about two percent
and CO2 emissions increased by 0.9
percent at the same time the European
Union
reduced its
uh CO2 emissions by 2.5 so we're
um good students and it's important to
highlight that
firstly two points firstly we need to
reduce our Imports it's not just about
replacing Russian gas by becoming uh
dependent on American or uh Chinese gas
we have to produce more at home reducing
demand Miss Simpson you're right we have
to do that but not to the detriment of
our industrial production
often there's a list link between energy
consumption and a country's wealth so we
have to be very Vigilant of that I think
the communication of the Net Zero act
next week
will allow us to move forward with clean
industry and the last point is this
strategic
energy autonomy of the EU we need to
produce more at home not just by
dismantling uh coal power plants
but particularly through renewable
energy and I hope that uh these
negotiations and delegated acts will
conclude shortly so that we can start
our hydrogen sector but nuclear as well
is a clean energy
and I'm glad that the uh energy agency
recognizes the role of nuclear in the
decarborisation of our world energy
industry sir do you agree that Europe
should continue to work on a regulatory
framework which is adapted to nuclear
energy to strengthen its existing
capacity
uh while working on solving problems
such as waste and Miss Simpson within
energy autonomy when are we going to
have a European nuclear Alliance for
tomorrow particular on a small modular
reactors I know that you've been working
on a partnership
but
in 2023 it's finally time to launch a
European Alliance on this thank you in
the name of the greens uh Mr dalonde
please
thank you chair and thanks to the
commissioner and to the director for
attending this meeting and discussing
these issues uh with us I have a
question regarding the balance between
the short term and the long-term
perspective on these issues because
let's remember why we are here we are
here because there was an opportunity
for Russia to use energy as a
geopolitical weapon and for us to be
vulnerable vulnerable because of it
because we are relying we are dependent
on fossil fuel and I think that the
image that the director showed on the uh
on the relative success that European
Union has had during 2022 why is this
because we invested a lot in Renewables
otherwise this had not been possible
and I am worried that many of the
proposals on the table right now will to
some extent reverse this and make it
more difficult this transition to more
inherently cheap sources of energy
enabling Renewables if we're using cfds
or if we are dividing the market into
several markets where fossil and nuclear
has a special price and are given some
extra support to be more
profitable
that can of course make some sense in
the very short term to alleviate price
but it also undermines the profitability
in investing in new Renewables
over the past few months I've met with
several stakeholders telling me that the
mere existence of these proposals dampen
the will of investments in your
Renewables only yesterday I met with a
Renewables company that doesn't dare to
invest in Renewables because they not
know how profitable they will be because
they see these proposals on the table
that might undermine the investments in
the kind of energy that will keep us
independent for the future thank you
foreign
polish
thank you very much commissioner
director executive chair thank you very
much for this opportunity to meet with
you today to speak with you I think at
this a crucial moment to look back and
with hindsight to sum up what we have
done what we have achieved and what we
haven't been able to achieved we have to
have a reliable hard data on which we'll
base our decisions for the future so I'm
very thankful that you speak about being
realistic about what we have to do the
energy crisis let me remind you did not
start when Russia attacked Ukraine let
me remind you how we discussed this back
in 2021 when we were afraid of
historical winter conditions so in fact
you know the pandemics played a role
because it disrupt after the supply
chains and this is where the crisis
started not When The War started
I'm happy to see that you are cautiously
optimistic but I have a question to both
the commissioner and the director
because um together with my colleagues
and experts I analyzed the report of the
um of your agency about the
Global Market of energy and on page 75
we read that
producing electric energy from a core
increased in this year by six percent
and you know there is a list of
countries that
restarted the call
um
um energy and you know these are the
countries ruled by socialists for
example so you know my question is about
coherence you know we are reinvesting in
Coal industry and also on the page 75 we
are talking about emissions from
electric energy and this is an increase
by seven percent you uh Mr director you
gave us aggregate data and rightly so
but if we break it down into individual
countries and this is what your report
mentions the situation in which in which
we are well we have to see uh what
different countries are doing we have to
show some solidarities you know you are
extremely demanding uh vis-a-vis my
country Poland but we see that other
countries are doing the exactly the same
and even more than Poland is doing in
the coal sector so you know it is simply
not coherent
the last intervention in the first round
Mr botenga the coordinator of the left
thank you very much Madam commissioner
and director
I think that uh we should take a few
moments in a presentation
to exercise some self-criticism
lots of citizens are criticizing the
commission for not having uh put a cap
on Energy prices and today we're still
paying the cost of that on a number of
levels Miss vandelayan was honest enough
to admit that the market had failed in
plenary I think it's the moment now to
reiterate that statement and draw the
conclusions from it you've talked about
our dependence on uh Russian fossil
fuels
but let's not forget that's the
consequence of years of policies
where we left
ecological transition to private
companies
they could get subsidies for green
energy but they could also get subsidies
for investing in fossil fuels
so regarding autonomy and the future
you've talked about Shale gas and liquid
natural gas and so on
however
the energy agents he also raised some of
the risks
if tomorrow the US decided to
stop exporting their liquid natural gas
entirely or in part to the European
Union and decided to sell it elsewhere
either
for political or economic reasons what
would the impact be on our economy
in other words
do you consider us to be a hostage of
the US
of a foreign country with whom we don't
always align on interests
we could do that same exercise for other
countries
with whom we're going to replace a
Russian inputs such as the Qatar Saudi
Arabia Azerbaijan or Kuwait which
as you know are not regimes that we
always share values with thank you
I'll kindly invite now first
commissioner Simpson and then executive
director be rolled to answer to these
questions but please do it in five six
minutes in order to have time for the
second round and then for the answers
and conclusions
I do my best to respect the time limit
but at the same time answer to all the
questions thank you for very uh
good discussion and comments I will
start with Christian ehler and and the
issue of our competitiveness at the high
prices first of all I do believe that
the temporary emergency measures that we
put in place helped us to achieve the
Target that we are facing right now that
prices for
Cole oil even oil gas and electricity
are year-on-year basis
significantly lower than they were last
year and
um
if uh if that has some impact then it
doesn't mean that we can be complacent
because we cannot continue pay hundreds
of billions of subsidies and this has
been possible also for our some
temporary measures that allowed member
states to re-route to the revenues to
the consumers but we need to continue
because diversification efforts and use
the joint purchasing to bring down the
gas prices and and of course this has
also effect on electricity prices and
third we need to ensure that our
industry and also our smes are less
exposed to volatility of
high prices of the short-term
electricity marketing that that's why I
will propose in the represent Market
design measures to facilitate access to
long-term instruments ppas and cfts
um
mainly for new Investments power
generation and this will help customers
benefit more directly from lower cost of
renewable generation but this also has
its impact to our industry our
green hydrogen sector
and and the last question about DDF
market and liquidity we just received
the report from asthma and they said
that clearly stated that there has not
been impact to liquidity in our gas gas
market only that allowed us to to move
further with extending this MCM to also
to other hubs
I do agree that filling the storage by
95 last November it was a success but
came at the cost at a high cost and
this is also one of the reasons why I
have organized a special meeting of the
gas security of Supply Group already in
February with all the stakeholders to
discuss best practices
um in feeling storage and new ways to
ensure that we achieve our Target this
year at a lower cost and based on this
input we are publishing soon a report on
the implementation of the storage
regulation with recommendations and best
practices and of course I'm happy to
discuss it with you and
[Music]
and there is also in parallel and
ongoing work to replace some of the
natural gases biomethane we created last
year industrial partnership biomethane
industrial partnership and as I I was
informing you the work is ongoing
um
Mr grudler the technology neutrality and
the role of nuclear
um well I am committed to respect
Technologic neutrality in our proposal
starting from the revision of the
electricity Market sign where this
principle will be reflected and from my
nij portfolio we want to bring two
issues on the focus first
security of fuel supply for the nuclear
industry
because we still do have file member
states who are dependent on Russian
nuclear Fuel and second promote the
competitiveness of the small modular
actors and the emergence of European
supply chain there and we are making
progress on the SMR partnership and and
I'm happy to keep you informed when the
dates will be agreed and but we can
already see that many member states are
taking steps to explore the deployment
of smrs and
um
and this is um also work supported by my
services
then
our challenge is short-term and long
term yes I do agree that that um
Renewables and acceleration of
Renewables is not anymore only about our
climate
commitments it is part of our security
supply policies and from the very
beginning this was our growth strategy
so last year we witnessed the record
volumes of new install capacity both
solar and wind and and actually
yesterday we had the solar power Summit
here in Brussels where my polish
colleague Minister mosquare was also one
of the keynote speakers because Poland
is not totally under under
um
um strong pressure to decarbonize but
they are doing excellently and and this
is visible both in in renewable site but
also in just transition regions
um and and of course right now member
states are in the process to upgrade
their National NHL climate plans I do
hope that that the common targets will
help us to achieve
[Music]
um
higher targets than than seeing Possible
only a couple of years ago
and and just to wrap up
I do believe that our electricity Market
uh
um
so far single integrated electricity
Market brings major economic and energy
Security benefits across the EU but it
is also clear that during this energy
crisis we have seen some shortcomings
and now with this electricity Market
reform proposal next week
um we do our utmost to bring the
benefits of low cost Renewables to all
the consumers thank you
thank you thank you so much
and thank you very much also very brief
answers
a
industrial policy is to have the right
industry policy for the next chapter of
the Industrial Age
is in my view not only a task for the
the colleagues who are working on
industry at least there are four other
areas that it needs to be involved in
making the Europe's next industrial
master plan one is the Energy Group
energy policy
second is the trade policy I think it is
time for Europe to show it is trade
masses
with the international partners
third is the foreign policy
we have to see with whom we are going to
work in terms of the Clean Energy
Technologies being alliances and being a
much stronger and thought is uh of
course it is the uh the fiscal policies
at if we need a coordination of this
four uh groups working with the industry
policy
now the last colleague in from the left
group mentions something which cause
most of the time unnoticed
renewable companies like any company
need to make impact profits
and currently many renewable companies
in Europe are not making profits
so the whatever the regulation
legislation we have
should make them to turn them to
companies which make profits therefore
they can make a Investments on open
employment opportunities I think this is
something that we sometimes forget we
all know that the cost of rooms are
going down but this is not necessarily
equal that the renewable companies are
making a profits
third point
a
nuclear
now
there are many countries in the world
when we look at the iea we look at not
only Europe the entire countries I can
tell you something very clearly
nuclear is making a comeback
around the world
Japan
imagine nuclear country changing this
policy restarting its nuclear power
plants and thinking of the next wave of
nuclear Korea exactly the same changing
its policies and coming back to the
previous nuclear policies
gov again from your Middle East India
China uh United States influence
reduction acts provides incentives for
the lifetime extension of nuclear power
plants existing ones and also of the
smrs and others Canada
and in Europe we all know that there are
different views
on nuclear but countries like from
Sweden to Netherlands Netherlands to
Poland France they all look at nuclear
very differently than they were looking
at a few years ago so therefore it is
not an exaggeration to say that nuclear
is making a comeback
now
of course every country makes its
decision by itself talking with their
people with the industry and take
decisions so but in my view if we talk
about the very effective medical
expansion this European domestic energy
production need to increase therefore
Europe's Reliance on the other countries
should decrease and
carbon natural way I believe nuclei can
emerge as an important option
my last two points Mr chairman
a participate of a philosophical point
but some countries have mentioned we are
at such a crossroad in terms of energy
and climate challenges we have and they
both magnitude of the challenge
and the lack of time in my view
they mean that there is a bigger role
for public institutions
governments to play vis-a-vis the
markets of course we are Market driven
markets are the ones Market Force are
the one who makes the decisions but if
we are face such immediate and strategic
challenges in front of our nose both
energy security and climate change we
should take which could have
geopolitical and humanitarian
consequences there is a role a stronger
role for public institutions being in
the driving seat
my last point
past policies
I believe
when the this crisis is over when the
dust settles
it is a time it will be a time for
European countries at least some
European countries
to make a self-critic
of their a major strategic choice of
building an economic model
based on important energy big time from
one single country
this is a huge strategic mistake
and many of us are paying it
not only with electricity and gas bills
but much beyond that so therefore it is
of course for not for Nam but then the
time comes we have to make this
discussion International Energy agency
will be following that discussion takes
place that that strategic decisions
being Reliant and fossil fuels of one
single country
one single company one trade route is
very risky and we have borne these years
and years and it will be the time that
we sit down and maybe discuss and make a
self-creating and and drive the lessons
from that thank you very much Mr
chairman
thank you thank you so much very true
I go now to the second round of
interventions interventions of one
minute please and I start of course with
President Erza buzek
thank you very much
dear Madam commissioner
and executive director it is always a
great pleasure to have you what is the
itra committee
a lot of information and great
discussion we survived as you said as
the European Union this winter and of
course our
gust or regulation was very very helpful
of course but now it's something
worrying because we are saying that
might be worse
next year
the the next year after after 2020 to
2025 so he's going where's and where's
why why we feel that it could be worse
we don't have any energy Supply from
Russia and we are ready to stop it
forever
so what is going worse probably because
we've got a very good repower EU
proposal from European commission
correct
but we don't have enough legal framework
for that
biomethane 35 billion cubic meter in few
years
it would be as a legal
obligation 10 million tons of hydrogen
and all the priority corridors for
hydrogen should be legal obligation
Madam commissioner it is just lying on
the table because in our
hydrogen gas package in Europe in
Parliament we've got everything written
in our regulation so we need your
support simply speaking
thank you to agree with the member state
that we should have all such of course
heat pumps should be also add to this
tremendous number of improvements
otherwise we will be worse and worse and
worse because we assume assume not more
not anymore
going back to Russia thank you so much
president okay
thank you very much and Mr director
General thank you very much for proposal
of new uh uh well point of view for our
industrial strategy it's very important
thank you so much Mr Gonzalez please
thank you very much chairman and thank
you
director
it's a shame that you weren't here
earlier on the subject of renewable
hydrogen because you would have seen
that some people want to use hydrogen
from gas rather than promoting
renewable hydrogen which would give us
autonomy and which would allow Europe to
lower energy prices Renewables are the
way forward you've said it so and if we
want to promote
renewable so we have to promote
policies that go in the direction not to
promoting
fossil fuels
or favoring
unreliable suppliers
so I think that's a very important
message
let's continue on the road to Renewables
which along with the diversification of
gas storage
is going to allow us to get through the
next winter as it has this one
now Madam commissioner on the market
elements
we need support for flexibility
will we introduce this in the next
Market reform
I think that's going to be necessary as
we increase Renewables in our Energy Mix
so I think that's a good path this is
visner please
continue thank you so much it was nice
to meet you both yesterday and it's also
very nice to welcome you to etra today
uh both to Miss Simpson and Mr birol
um many of the European countries that
have they are not so reliant on Russian
gas have one thing in common and that's
a factor I would like to bring up to the
table now and that's the the bioenergy
and especially the case I think one of
the best examples is Lithuania thanks to
the production of bioenergy they were
able they were able to face out their
dependency on Russian gas long before
the war started and you Mr brawl and the
IAA presented the report in March 2022
where you said that Europe could double
the energy production from bioenergy and
to in order to fast phase out the Russia
natural gas despite so the repower EU
only mentions bioenergy ones hydrogen is
mentioned over 50 times so I would like
to hear both Mr barole how do you see
that you European Union is neglecting
your advice on this not bringing
bioenergy into the the possible of
Solutions in the repower EU and what do
you think the EU could do in terms of
enhancing it and and utilizing the
potential of the bioenergy policies and
to the commissioner Madam Simpson
dude how do you see the red discussions
on bioenergy actually risking doing the
opposite uh lowering in the the
potential of using bioenergy as a part
of the solution also the court case on
biogas how we will make sure that the
court case on lowering the tax on biogas
will not hamper the deployment of
biomethane within the repower EU the
court case was only so much
please
also want to come back to a suggestion a
few which was not yet discussed at all
it's Energy Efficiency because this is
we are dealing with intensively
currently so um you made quite some
proposals also beside heat pumps which
is a problem what we heard but I would
like to hear your opinion you know what
has been done internal what had has been
reached also with the view to this maybe
more difficult summer because we should
talk about it and put pressure and maybe
have your advice on what kind of support
we need from governments in this regard
thanks
thank you so much Mrs paulus please
thank you very much and thank you both
for your inspiring inputs and your clear
words I would like to briefly focus on
two points first we will enter into the
maybe last fry log on the Energy
Efficiency directive this afternoon and
if the EU continues to neglect this
Energy Efficiency despite of the new
realities that Dr Beryl has just
outlined we will not be able to handle
not only the next winter but also the
years ahead let's not forget that Energy
Efficiency is the base load of the
energy transition and my question to you
commissioner is will you commit to
staying strong on the commission's
repower EU Targets this afternoon or
this night second the global methane
tracker of the Ia produces a number of
roughly 5 million tons of methane being
emitted in the energy sector of the
European Union but taking a look over
our borders it's at least triple that
amount in the Mena region alone
so Dr Beryl how would you judge the
effect of including Imports in the EU
legislation on limiting methane
emissions in the energy sector would
that alleviate our situation and
apologies I have to leave because I have
to fulfill my duty as coordinator in the
special Kobe committee but I will watch
the recording for your answers thanks a
lot thank you so much Mrs
thank you Tim I'll be speaking in
Bulgarian
exposure
Madam commissioner Mr beta all their
colleagues
right now there is a bit of a lull uh in
the prices of natural gas as to what we
have in comparison to what we had in the
beginning but the way the prices are set
up this shock has moved to the bills
this last production and it will be less
production some even stopped producing
electricity
there's a big problem with the
commodities for example foodstuffs in
many member states the prices of skyrose
rocketing because of the electricity
prices there is a ban on the import of
vegetables some restrictive practices or
freezing of prices
in countries where people spend most of
their money on foodstuffs this leads to
huge inflation and a lot of pressure on
household that is why the reform of this
Market should focus on how the prices
are set up so what are the specific
measures you would take in order to
reduce the energy prices and the
inflation in Europe thank you
thank you very much Mr Sean Kelly please
EPP
thank you and thanks to commissioner and
the director for very interesting
messages and presentations
so some questions one if China is
growing again
is there a likelihood that rather than
competing against ourselves and others
on the world market
that they will look to Russia
to give them the growing need they have
for energy
I will be hosting later on today
uh an event on that electricity Market
design reform on behalf of your electric
and that of course will have to direct
investment into Renewables as well as
storage Technologies and demand side
flexibility but also I'm interested to
ask the commissioner
where they should see the United Kingdom
fitting into our situation now that
we've agreed hopefully on the Windsor
framework and back in good terms again
especially in relation to cross-border
electricity trading and the single
electricity Market in Ireland
and the final question how will the new
legislation Aid multi-purpose
interconnectors which are so badly
needed thank you very much
thank you so much Mr Patterson please
Master over committee renew thank you
thank you chair and uh thank you
commissioner and and and thank you
director I think uh Kathleen you point
out to some of the big and great
successes so far I was especially happy
to hear you
your ambition of prolonging the 15
obligation or savings obligation at
least I think that is exactly the right
tool one of the many right tools to
apply in this situation in order to
ensure that we get through next window
as well so thanks for for this now now
doctor uh all I can assure you have many
uh readers in this room of of your great
Publications and and congratulations uh
we we really applaud it now I also
wanted to touch upon the Energy
Efficiency issue because uh you didn't
point to this in in your great slides
two questions basically uh are we doing
enough on Energy Efficiency I mean I
know the easy answer is no obviously not
but but could you elaborate a little on
this and what what kind of suggestions
uh iea might have to us on on this
secondly on the Renewables
to consider this in the big picture uh
related to energy security is is
absolutely right and and and and and on
this point as well are we doing things
fast enough I know the easy answer again
here is is no you're pointing out to 41
editions of solar and wind in your slide
but clearly if we are to meet our
targets we have to ramp up much faster
than what we're capable of doing so
please a couple of words from this as
well thank you so much and congrats with
all your great work we we appreciate it
thanks thank you so much Mr Guyer please
thank you very much chairman
I was listening attentively when you
were talking about the burdens on
European industry
talked about these fact of the exposed
to Future Energy prices I'm somewhat
disappointed that everything we've read
in the commission proposals for a new
common organization marking on
electricity
accommodating European industry on
measures such as reducing electricity
prices is missing
so it was
Simpson I'd be appreciative as that if
you can tell me why this is
there are examples from the German
Institute for economy for example
that
replacement measures could be thought up
for a pool of contracts for difference
where European business could be kitted
out
to be able to deal with competitive
electricity prices I'd just like to put
that out in the room if you've got
something spontaneous on that I'd
appreciate it Dr Bureau as well for much
Mrs Vice please
thank you so much and thank you for
being with us this morning Dr pirol it's
very appreciative how precise you are in
your recommendations
now I have a question regarding
digitalization in October 2022 the
commission adopted an energy action plan
that aims to support development of
sustainable cyber secure and competitive
market for digital Energy Services now I
will not ask you if you think that was
the timely Act
uh it entails the creation of a common
European energy data Space by 2024 it's
about coordination at EU level and also
it points out that investments in
digitalization is very key now
considering the need and the importance
of digitalization in the energy sector
to ensure that there are more Renewables
in the grid and to improve grid
flexibility and reliability despite the
intermittent nature of Renewables what
should be
the most important aspects or policy
measures that we as policy makers should
focus on what are the one two most
important points for us to act upon
regarding digitalization and energy when
we leave this very very important
meeting
thank you thank you thank you so much
thank you thank you chair and thank you
commissioner Simpson and Mr Burrell
I want to talk about the money
and I particularly want to talk about
Energy Efficiency Deputy Hildegard uh
Deputy Peterson both talked about Energy
Efficiency
which always seems to be the bridesmaid
but never the bride it seems to be
overlooked uh what can we do about this
as the reporter on the recast energy
performance of buildings directive I'm
delighted to see the strong interest in
buildings uh which consume 40 of energy
if we tackle buildings we're well on our
way to reducing energy use and indeed uh
tackling our climate goals
um but how can we step up the finance at
a European level we're talking about a
hydrogen bank which is great and yes we
need that but we also need the money for
renovations and thankfully the European
Investment Bank is strongly rebranding
as the climate Bank the European Central
Bank has came out in strong support for
an energy performance of buildings
directive but can we do more about
releasing the money for renovations and
in doing so ensure that Energy
Efficiency makes center stage thank you
thank you thank you so much Mr barenson
please
PPP
thank you very much
um as the robot of the European
Parliament Zone the industry strategy I
completely
share uh the call of Mr b-roll uh on
what is needed for industry and for our
competitiveness competitiveness
competitiveness has been an issue raised
by the Epp uh continuously over the last
years and indeed the energy price is is
one of the main aspects for our industry
to be competitive in the coming years as
well and therefore I I really hope that
that next week and in the coming weeks
when the proposals of the commission are
presented that we somehow see something
of also a a 10e on steroids because I
think we need cross-border projects
cross-border infrastructure to tackle
the energy energy transition and the
energy prices together in in Europe and
I have a very concrete question to Mr
b-roll in your reports of the
iea
of December you mentioned that the eu's
potential gas supply demand Gap could
reach 27 billion cubic meters in 2023
and I'm wondering where we are now thank
you
thank you so much Mr Heiser please
yeah thank you thank you chair uh the
commissioner uh I I would like to ask
you you know uh we really managed to
secure enough of energy sources for this
winter but uh because we were held also
by the weather as it was set also by the
absence of the China on the LNG Market
it's also positive that Europe uh will
end with uh relatively large stocks this
winter it's okay yeah but do you expect
that the storage uh will be filled to
the level about the 90 percent also by
this November without major problems I
mean taking account it also uh for the
last year we feel the storage also by
the Russian gas my second question is um
one of uh the possible this is really
not popular because we are dealing with
a green deal is to increase our
resilience of the EU in case of the oil
and gas supplies is rely on our own
reserves it means exploration and
eventual extraction yeah of of the
deposits that we have in Europe what is
your view on this for example an account
the Netherland and what has happened
happening in Netherlands and do you see
it also has an opportunity to strengthen
energy security because despite the
obvious trends of the decarbonation we
will need these fuels for I don't know
maybe 10 years at least thanks
thank you thank you very much Mr Hazel
uh Mrs Cornelius the greens
thank you very much thank you to miss
Simpson and Mr b-roll
I'd like to touch on a different aspect
that hasn't been mentioned yet we're
saying yes we want to leave Russian
energy Imports behind we want to be
independent of those fair enough
nevertheless we need Natural Gas
we've spoken about Norway to date but
there are also countries in the global
South
in Africa for example where there's Iran
in Senegal as well where there are
massive investments in completely new
fossil fuel infrastructure going on
and of course in this conjunction we
need to look at the lock-in effect being
avoided with these investments in new
fossil fuel infrastructure so my
question is quite simple when you're
talking to countries in the global South
how do you view that who are the most
important providers of natural gas how
do you estimate the political role in
future as well of say Senegal these sort
of countries probably others as well and
what's your level of knowledge of
negative impacts the negative
environmental impacts that can come of
this again please
thank you chair I switched to Italian
um grazia
thank you very much commissioner and Dr
Bill for this very interesting
presentation
I think all the subjects were touched on
but as other colleagues I would
underline
the issue
of funding the transition
and all the energy projects associated
with it
I think the quick adoption of repower EU
and all the actions this year has shown
us
that we can respond to an energy shock
if we do it together
just as the way just as we did to the
shock of the pandemic however
we're going to really need a
transitional funding
where other players such as the US are
still quite strong
the IRA is a slap that really resonated
discussions on state aid is not enough
we have to make sure that our single
Market is not at risk
we're looking forward to receiving the
proposal on the reform of the
electricity Market but we see that today
now we have strategic companies closing
because the threefold energy costs are
not sustainable
please
thank you thank you chair and thank you
commissioner and Dr viral for being here
with us and it is important to have the
details from the horse mouth but I would
like to stick on the on the early
warning coming from Western particularly
not only on the on the issue that the
next window will be much more difficult
than the current one but also on the
issue that it is we have to look for for
solutions that they are combining the
the addressing of the challenges of
climate change and also the energy
security issues in this regard I would
like to focus on this with the of the
green hydrogen and relation developments
we have here in the EU concerning the
legislation Madam commissioner my
question is this a lot of concerns are
coming from from the industry uh
regarding the the due delegate attacks
that are they are drafted and are in
place uh this period And I would like to
ask you if you are going to proceed with
clarifications in order to to address is
the concerns coming from the industry at
the same time it is also important to
ask Mr birole if he has some kind of
specific suggestions in order to have a
fast track development deployment of
hydrogen of green hydrogen deployments
in order to to increase the security of
supply thank you so much Mr foxland our
reporter for Energy Efficiency
thank you chair thank you
Mrs Simpson and Mr pyrol for your
analysis
I am the rapper of the Energy Efficiency
directive which will we we will be
negotiating later today with the
commissioner and the council and we are
struggling here in the European
Parliament to keep a high level of
ambition we know that from the analysis
of the commission that one-third of the
natural gas savings from the fit for 55
package will have to come from the NFD
efficiency directive and that is why we
want a high Target and we think that the
repower EU proposal from the commission
is a good one so I'd like to ask uh
fatsi Mr fatsi Bureau on how you see the
role for Energy Efficiency in the
analysis that you presented to begin
with if we are to meet these challenges
of which you speak
how how important will Energy Efficiency
be and what will your advice to us be in
relation to this area Energy Efficiency
thank you
thank you so much last intervention Mr
Bloss please
I think he needed to live
then uh
many many questions also suggestions I
kindly invite you now to answer to to
this and then of course Mr birol uh
please commissioner Simpson
thank you and I very much enjoyed our
open exchange Fields today
um as you know Parliament has invited me
to be in front of plenary next Tuesday
um on on topic how we can ensure
Security in the EU energy Security in
the EU this year so I will
um try to be very brief so that Dr
Bernal will have more time because we
will enjoy an hour on Tuesday but I will
start with Dr Professor buzak's question
why we are worried about this winter
this is very simple Russia still
delivered 60 billion cubic meters of gas
via pipeline last year to Europe and the
rest that they didn't deliver anymore
they were not able to sell to
Alternative markets because they don't
have alternative pipeline Network that
means that was lost to Global markets
and as I mentioned there is 60 more to
lose we were able to replace partially
this this LNG but LNG markets this year
will be significantly more competitive
because to the demand from Asia so we
know that we have to replace the
remaining gas with Renewables and we
have to prioritize savings so I
um I assure you NH efficiency is a top
priority of ours without savings without
prolonging also our temporary measures
to cut gas consumption but also to
prioritize these efforts that member
states made to cut electricity Peak our
consumption we will be in difficult more
difficult situation and that of course
means that that you can expect that we
will address all the remaining pattern
next so not any more permitting that we
have addressed but we have lack of
skilled Workforce Supply chains for some
renewable sectors are too
well too long and and of course greets
well you can shorten the permitting but
if our trees are not able to connect all
those installations we are missing the
Target and and as I uh mentioned these
some of these um uh we will address uh
next week in our anatzero industrial Act
and um and from my side in the longer
perspective this year I want to propose
also industrial partnership to work on
skills and to push the new Eco design
and then actually labeling of cooling
and heating appliances so that we can
replace in building sector fossil fuels
with heat pumps and and then of course
we are very dependent on our trusted
Partners there was a question about our
cooperation with UK you have praised a
lot our partners from Norway and
Azerbaijan and Algeria and United States
but of course UK is also like-minded
partner who accelerates offshore wind
and has delivered some very necessary
gas in previous year and I hope that our
cooperation is now on steady base thank
you see you tomorrow not tomorrow this
evening and next week
thank you thank you so much commissioner
Please Mr mirror please thank you Mr
chairman so Mr chairman first of all I
think it is the last round uh we are
talking I uh it's the first time I came
to this Committee in person I can't tell
I am very impressed with the questions
and the very surprised with the fact
that many of you read our reports I am
really honored for that and I will tell
my colleagues when I go back to Paris
and in response chairman may I offer the
members of this Parliament when they
were to come to Paris I have a wonderful
office with the Eiffel Tower review
Awareness coffee machine to invite you
to come to my office and have a
discussion on these issues more in that
and thank you very much for your
interest once again invitation accepted
and thank you for this thank you but
please one by one so not always at the
same times I have a small office
thank you very much much appreciated
so um Mr chairman uh first of all uh Mr
buzek said why don't we stop completely
uh next year we have to think of 2017
2019 2030 that the Reliance on the
Russian girls or other countries yes now
the energy sector is a very particular
sector it is not like the I.T sector if
you don't like your iPhone you can
change it immediately
but energy sector is bond with a huge
infrastructure and a consuming
equipments it is like a not like a
bicycle like it's like a big tanker and
you changed the route very very slowly
unfortunately therefore as I start to
say we made a huge mistake
in Europe by having a over-reliance on
one country's fossil fuel exports it is
in my view we said several times to
those countries to put all the bags in
one basket was a strategic mistake and
in my view I'm an energy person not an
energy mistake but as a foreign policy
mistake and a geopolitical uh mistake so
therefore it will take some time we are
going in the right direction we can
definitely accelerate this
and we can definitely learn from this
lesson and the steps we take should be a
based on these lessons one of them is
the questions one of the colleagues
asked from which countries we can get a
new gas Imports
now there's a lot of discussion we know
all the countries how much each country
where the gas reserves how much they can
export and what does it cost
but I think as Europe we have to be very
careful
because we have a energy security
problem now but we have another
challenge which is the climate change we
shouldn't forget and we should be proud
that the Europe was the champion years
and years of fighting against climate
change we shouldn't leave it to the
other countries so therefore when I look
at the numbers before the invasion
European gas consumption was in a
decline already
it was declining
now the The Gas We are going to find
should be the one that will replace the
Russian gas we would need and in that
respect since the European economy
should not be relying disproportionately
on gas the gas contracts we are going to
make country X Y or Z
I hope it should be diverse should be as
much as possible
short-term contracts
and the projects we are making to import
that cash transported cars should be
designed in a way that that can be
repurposed to use hydrogen in the future
so these are the two things that I would
like to bring to attention right
countries
flexible and not long-term contracts as
much as possible and also designed the
infrastructure accordingly that they can
be repurposed
the issue I am so happy to hear the
medical expansion Energy Efficiency
in Europe
every country has an energy a potential
some countries have oil some have gas
some have huge in the world some have
called some have a hydropower
but all the countries have won energy
source potential which is Energy
Efficiency
and in Europe we got it we did a good
job up to now but there is a huge
potential to improve it which means that
is put very eloquently it is a base lot
of our Energy System
how do we do it there are two ways
one providing incentive for the
consumers to do it
in terms of consumers what kind of
incentives more financial incentives
in terms of buildings for example one of
the colleagues mentioned the buildings
today in Europe we are we have a very
old building stock
and we are renovating only one person of
our buildings each year to be in line
with our climate Targets in Europe fit
455 it should be three times higher
renovation in the buildings so one area
is providing incentive for uh efficiency
and the other one is in line with fat
asset in the previous round the public
sector being in the driving seat a bit
more in than in the past regulations
standards and Norms they should be
stricter and sticker in my view and
there are long-term uh standards Norms
of regulations and as Madam
Commissioners
for the next a year having the 15
percent Claus is a good one
methane so when we talk about climate
change we talk all the time on carbon
dioxide emissions
but there is other one which is a bit
more uh under the shadow of CO2 carbon
dioxide but it is even more dangerous
because in the short term it is getting
a lot of problem for us
and but the good news is
reducing methane emissions is much
easier and much less costly
75 percent of the global methane
emissions in the world today can be
minimized and notified at no cost at no
cost if you take the right measures
because it is basically fixing the pipes
that they don't methane doesn't leak gas
doesn't leak I just make it too extreme
but just to make sure that you don't
need a big technology you don't need to
discover anything you just need the the
oil and gas industry not to be greedy
but to make the investments in order to
make the necessary take the necessary
steps so therefore it is the eu's
position in terms of
the gas Imports putting the methane
emission
is an important uh item is in my very
good and in my view there may be even a
room for making them even a thicker so
methane please let's keep a eye on that
say again the question uh are what can
we do more in Renewables we can do many
things but if I can if I if you give me
the right to ask for one thing only
you know why we had a big increase last
uh a year
because of the following many countries
were in a problem how can we bring
energy so therefore they did something
that they didn't do long times they have
cut the permitting and Licensing time
so this is the it creates a lot of lot
of problem that a lot of projects are in
the bureaucratic phases of getting the
the licensing from a permitting from the
authorities governments need to do one
small thing
increase the workforce in the permitting
licensing bureau's offices and make it
much more nimble
so this is the if you ask me one thing I
am a
pragmatic man this is the when I look at
we could talk with the companies and of
course every company when I talk to
business they always a tax instantly
they send it but the main issue is today
the fault line is permitting and losses
and takes a lot of time in Europe please
please please shorten it as much as
possible if it is one thing I would like
to mention that two last points Mr
chairman I know that you want me to
finish yes two last points
in my view bio energy is the blind spot
of the the European energy debate in
general with the ngos with everything
together we have a lot of potential
there in terms of bioenergy if we play
our cards uh well we can make a
significant amount of uh contribution I
have to just sat and stop it here
especially in some countries it can make
a substantial contribution if we play
our cards uh right
a last two points I'm sorry one in the
uh grits and digitalization other one is
uh on hydrogen now
dear colleagues just let me tell you one
thing very helicopter View
we have oil gas Renewables this and that
hydrogen but when I look at the global
energy pictures where it came and
talking with the investors companies
where it will go governments I can't
tell you something very simple
the future is electric
the global Energy System will be more
and more electric it is under
transportation how we our Mobility
system how we at home how we use energy
for heating for for everything our
industry sector the transistors and the
electricity side electricity will be
very important for in our lives less
fossil fuels oil gas called less
molecules and more electricity now here
what is important we all want to see new
power plants solar and wind some of us
nuclear some of this but
the veins if you think you have the body
human body the veins the is the Greece
have strong how well designed have
modern and how flexible our grits are
and what makes our grits more smart much
efficient and much better in terms of
the electricity movement is the
digitalization
so the right digital policy merit with
the right clean energy policy is the the
formula for the success for Europe and
as well
for hydrogen
a
in fact when you look at Europe there is
one lesson we have to learn and I have
to imagine this Mr chairman we all talk
about solar energy and I show you a
chart that today China produces about 90
percent of the solar panels in the world
but
20 years ago
the picture was very different
it was Germany it was Spain it was Italy
started the The Solar put a lot of
subsidies but after a few years they
dropped the ball and China continued and
today Chinese leader
energy technology is lacking running a
marathon
that's 42 kilometers Europe run the
marathon first 10 kilometers in the
front
but then slow down get tired thought of
something yes and China came and left
past Europe and became number one nobody
nobody gives a gold medal in the
marathon who finishes the 10 kilometers
as the first
if you want to get to gold medal you
have to finish the 42 kilometers first
which means the policies
the right policy is put in place and
giving a confidence to the investors
and it is the reason I'm saying that for
the hydrogen for the electrolyzers we
have to give a visibility to the
investors
Financial visibility
this is the only thing I would like to
say in terms of hydrogen but we should
be aware that today in terms of cost
competitiveness Europe is not
the very best place we have to improve
that and second maybe last warning
please please
hydrogen
not today and even not tomorrow will be
soul of our problems maybe the day after
tomorrow so please do not expect it the
hydrogen will uh resolve all of our
problems from one day other it will grow
it will with the increasing demand of
giving them incentives but to have a
fixation that the hydrogen will solve
our problems in the short or even the
medium term would be taking our
attention from the solutions that we
have under our hands now and to lose
some perhaps time and attention just
wanted a friendly warning here Mr
chairman I stop here thank you thank you
so much it was really a very interesting
meeting a privilege to have commissioner
caddy Simpson executive director berol
together with us today with this I
formally closed the meeting see you next
time thank you very much colleagues we
run to the press conference
thank you